[Music]
season 25 of dancing with the stars and
it's official newlyweds and newly
parents max and peta are back
[Music]
max peta and uncle val are all coming
back and peter's got plans to bring baby
shy around too shy is older now i would
love to have him on set more um last
time he was just so young also big news
congratulations mark ballas is back on
dancing with the stars i can't wait to
see what my best friend comes up with
today former pro derek huff had nothing
but love for mark who took two seasons
off to star on broadway mark debated the
decision for a few months if they asked
you to come back dancing would you do it
i don't know i don't know yet man he
ultimately said yes because he missed
his friends he'll join familiar faces
including shaurna artem gleb keogh
whitney lindsay and last season's champ
emma slater let me give you the mirror
ball
not on the list it must beyonce sasha
farber no word on why but he tweeted a
sad face this morning possibly taking a
spot guys this is the most exciting
thing in the world
23 year old alan bersten he's a longtime
troop member and stepped up when max got
injured to dance with heather morris he
told us this spring he was hoping for
pro status knock on wood i hope this
next season is my time and tonight we've
learned one more pro will be announced
with the celebs next month our dancing
source says that spot will go to
two-time winner cheryl burke but you do
see yourself going back at some point in
some capacity absolutely for sure well
one person not dancing with any pro
bachelorette rachel lindsay yeah tells
us that it is not likely she's going to
be on the show because she is focusing
on her relationship with brian michelle
turner joining me now and i think that's
a good idea because you got to spend too
much time rehearsing she can't be all
like focusing on that relationship you
know i think that's a great idea because
we know what happens on those shows
[Music]